foreign
I think you are one of the best
moderators I've ever seen and it's true
and that that is absolutely I would say
that to anyone I think I'm actually
pretty sure I have said it publicly you
have actually thank you for that yeah
and I'd like to look at the mechanics
and the preparation that goes into that
because you've talked to me about this
and I remember one of the examples again
which is hyperspecific which is
if you guys are on Zoom which most
people are not going to see like raising
your hand and using visual cues for
things so could you walk through
what the preparation process looks like
for a good episode we build a docket
every week for all in the docket I took
from Red Scare which is
like this Dirtbag Left podcast of these
two
women who live in the
Times Square in New York right they're
quite charming and hilarious I
probably a little Cutting Edge for some
people but anyway the Red Scare pockets
is hilarious and dash always says oh
what's on the docket and have a docket
like you know these are the people who
are we're gonna pass judgment on like
before a judge so we have a docket I
make a docket every week with my
producer Nick and basically we're in a
group chat and whatever links we share
that week we put in there and then we
put bullet points so the docket is a
Google doc yeah Google doc of topics and
then this is put into a private slack
channel that you guys use or something
like that okay we're on Signal yeah and
so we yeah that's why they all disappear
within a week
our lessons to learn
thank you for getting it so anyway
signal can't reach me on Signal so now
do you use desktop client for that to
make it easier to use or do you do it
all on mobile signal is desktop and
mobile now yeah it's pretty great and
it's not owned by the Russians do you
use mobile I use mobile and I use a
desktop yeah okay great anyway I have
the bullet points in there
and I will sometimes push people to come
up with topics so like hey when
Friedberg was kind of sitting back a lot
of the episodes I kind of dubbed him the
Sultan of Science and I kind of created
this character and I said you know
listen you're you're kind of like a
little bit of a Wallflower last episode
can you give me
one of the most interesting science
story of the week is if I don't get one
by you know whatever a day before taping
I'm like hey and maybe I'll do a little
research myself hey what do you think of
this or what about that and when I get a
science topic out of him I throw to him
and you know he just lights up it's
great and then you know tomorrow will
make a joke or sax will go check his
email and then sucks I throw him red
meat so like the red meat for sacks is
like anything political anything to do
with the Constitution anything to do
with the Supreme Court or legal cases
and then if I want to give uh an
alley-oop to chamoth so I think about us
the moderator I gotta get out of this
guy I gotta get him engaged Freeburg I
gotta give him some science so that he
gets excited right he's not excited to
talk about politics because he doesn't
like it
with sacks I got a tiger yeah and all
like a like a fierce tiger and if I
throw you know a couple of chickens out
there he's gonna Maul them and I know
what they are so I'm like okay here you
go Supreme Court decision loses his mind
oh here you go Biden said this and it's
inconsistent or boom hey here's
something with Trump he's gonna just go
crazy so now you got your lying going
crazy you got your science nerd coming
out of his shell and then with chemath
it's more like an alley-oop sweaters
sweaters Laura piano
conspicuous consumption no it really is
more about markets and startups and for
him I like to say to him
can you explain
this financial topic and why people are
talking about interest rates are bad for
tech companies why would the interest
rate have any impact on that now I know
the answer to that
but he can actually explain it better
than anybody on the squad yep so what
I'm doing there as the point guard is
like I have a clear path to the basket I
can just lay it in and do the layout but
I see him out of the corner of my eye
and I'm like you know what to make the
audience have a better experience is if
I pretend I'm gonna do the layup and
then from behind my back I throw it up
to him and he slam dunks it right and so
I've I've learned with each of them how
to feature them and make them really
their best selves
and then behind the scenes you know when
you see the point guard in basketball
like take somebody and they whisper in
their ear or something
I very quietly give them notes on their
performance and this is after each
episode after each show I did it had to
do it more earlier and then sometimes
I'll do it in the group chat if I think
it's something everybody can benefit
from but more often than not I'm doing
it quietly yep and so I you know I had
to say to Freeburg listen you know you
don't say a lot about politics
but I think your opinion actually
represents a large portion of the
audience and although you hate it I
think you expressing a little bit
is going to be fine and if you're not
happy with how it comes out and I think
it's putting you at risk I will tell you
when we can cut it from the show and
once I gave him that sort of like I
think a little bit of a clear land
encouragement you will hear him talk a
little bit more about politics not to
the extent to access and then I had to
tell sacks hey sax when when I ask you
something or I challenge you
I am not disagreeing with you
I'm helping you clarify your position or
helping the audience understand your
position more that's very very smart way
to put it and you are attacking me
telling me I'm watching MSNBC and I get
my information from Rachel Maddow I
didn't ask you
to explain like one time I said just to
be clear
Putin invaded Ukraine not Biden correct
and he just went off or whatever and I
said you know the reason I'm asking you
that is because the audience thinks and
the feedback online is you're a Putin
apologist it would help your position if
you said to the audience
Putin and Putin alone is responsible for
invading Ukraine now how we manage Putin
and his unjust immoral invasion
is you know up to us right yeah and
that's what we can debate but I'm trying
to save him from being misunderstood
right and so you're like one part
moderator one-part coach one part comes
director
well in a way I'm not saying that is a
bad thing it's just no no no I think
it's super accurate yeah you're helping
everybody what I realized was I've done
you and I have done you know hundreds of
interviews with people great it's
awesome we're both interested in people
and learning from them and having great
conversations but this because became
something different for me you know like
being the orchestrator of the action oh
it's a different skill different skill
it was a totally different skill and you
know I had done these moderations before
at events but and I had sometimes done
round tables news roundtables but a lot
of times I was one of the featured
players not the point guard right may I
give one example of why they're totally
different in a one-on-one conversation
you can have a guest who monologues if
you have a group of people that can be a
huge problem how do you deal with that
specifically yeah it's two techniques
yeah two techniques very good so you and
I like technique so the two techniques I
have one of them is I say to people
beforehand
great job on the show today
at this moment in time you made four
really great points
it would have been better if you made
your first one or two
and then said I'm really interested in
what sex thinks of that or I'm curious
that's what you think and then you have
those two just write them on a piece of
paper there there'll be time for those
too we'll Circle back around but now it
doesn't look like you're taking all the
chips off the table because in a
conversation with four smart people
about a topic there might be five good
points to make
all four people might understand all
five points or four of the points and
then if somebody comes in and they're
just like
you know ding ding ding ding ding I just
took all the good points yeah there's
nothing left for anybody else to do and
so you want to share the ball a little
bit you took two good points you let
somebody else make a good point yeah you
could have made that point it was an
obvious one but you let somebody else
have it's a little bit generous as a
performer so it'd be like you know you
got some incredible guitar player they
come out and they just do a solo of six
minutes
Piano guy I could have done a solo for a
minute you could have done two we could
have given the drummer a minute and we
could have let the vocalist lead off the
song with an acapella you know moment
right yeah and so I've really tried to
be better at it and specifically try to
be better at it because people have been
critical of me
for interrupting certain people and so I
had to actually adapt to that because
certain people if you interrupt them
it's a trigger for them yeah or it can
break their train of thought I ran into
this recently and I was like I was I
wondered how like how would Jason handle
this I was curious so I came up with
another one I said I'm going to give you
the circle so if people aren't watching
right now I'm just taking my index
finger and I'm just giving the wrap up
sign but I'm also nodding so I'm saying
yeah
good stuff you know I'm giving you the
good stuff but like hey let's wrap that
point and then I'll just stop and they
finish their thought
and the other thing I do is I just use
okay
and I got that from Sam Harris I was
listening to those Sam's podcasts
he gets people monologuing
these are some of the most brilliant
academics in the world on his show and
you'll see sometimes he wants to break
in
but I think in Academia it's even more
like difficult to do that just for
boating yeah for boat and that's the
word I was looking for my dyslexia was
killing me on that one
written it's for both right you let
people finish but he'll say okay
and it's like okay I got it okay you did
it and then the person's like oh oh Sam
has something to add and that's in a
one-on-one situation so you know you you
get good by studying you know I study a
lot of what you do and I you know you
have a way
when you're asking
a question of slowing down
and it's almost as if you're bringing us
into your brain for the formation of the
question
and I that was me imitating you yeah I
figured yeah and when you do it it's
like somebody at a dinner party who's
talking in a lower voice and everybody
leans in I know it's going to be a
[ __ ] important question when you do
that and I don't know if you've it's
unconscious or it's conscious yeah or
you are truly forming the question
but when listening to Tim Ferriss
when Tim slows down and Tim is thinking
I want to ask you one more question
I have it on this note here it's hold on
now it means it's a really important
question and it really does work as a
technique and you know everybody's
techniques doesn't have to work for
everybody like I talk fast yeah you talk
a little slower or more methodically say
I'm talks even you know more monotone he
speaks in finished Pros unless it's
about Trump and then he gets on dealt